etwas unruhig war es bei dieser
päpstlichen audienz am mittwoch ein
kleiner junge rannte auf die bühne beim
papst herum zwischenzeitlich inspizierte
er auch die wache der schweizergarde
später kam sogar noch ein kleines
mädchen hin zu den papst schien das
alles wenig zu stören
amüsiert schaute er dem treiben zu und
kommentierte er ist argentinier sehr
undiszipliniert
die mutter des jungen hatte franziskus
diese informationen offenbar in einem
kurzen gespräch mitgeteilt als sie
versuchte die kinder von der bühne zu
holen
demnach ist der junge stumm und kann
nicht sprechen ausdrucksstarke und
kommunikativ ist er aber auf jeden fall
zugleich segnete auch die rosenkränze
und die übrigen anders gegenstände wie
sie dafür mitgebracht